I want you to be the real Mario okay
never tried this before so just I feel
horribly well start world one water I
believe I can go a lot faster than anis
I'm going to give this a shot
she's going to fail come on is believes
whisper spot we invited an out join us
for some real Mario simulation happening
here the camera right there yeah the
Carmichael has a little gamble here is
wirelessly transmitting the video signal
to these goggles so we are going to wear
this while we run the course I'm really
strong Bob with the barrio yeah yes
everyone has fun
he did it
oh it's the greatest challenge of them
all to the Koopa shell so I just don't
like Illmatic Koopa
yes destroyed fishel so theoretically I
would have stopped the shell if you're
harder than playing Mario way harder
harder
all right we're going to raise the
stakes to Jake we're going to add an
enemy and then I need to be swinging a
sword totally out of seat and then at
his head and Jake's gonna have to
somehow defeat them I'm not sure how
he's going to do that we'll let him
figure that out on the spot there look
like an appropriate enemy my first time
going in
I can't wait to Jack in Oh what's up hog
is so disorienting oh I know where you
are I always do it means of rise to be
great oh you're already way off man
you're way off you're way off get back
there yeah that's right yeah
I cannot stop
[Music]
he activated over it next time more
speed this whole time we've been kind of
easygoing on people with a hurdle shelf
this time we go writer and feet go and
hide on the box do is the trick in the
box falling off the box
digging backwards progress then go
backwards and Mario all right here he
goes
dance the question mark thinking about
it go on run speed it up oh he's turning
ahead stop it he's doing a really bad
job there's no depth perception oh my
god he just took out the question mark
holder alright Hugo's the guy get around
and sword this is so far off target I
was not expecting rain to be the worst
of this anything in the bulk around
about who he did bring it down there
sorry I cook from the feet
Brendan's like Gandhi so many one up but
out great it's also das those
oh wow nice so great
oh man dude I was great got really
disoriented so bright out here that was
really good jumping or that show I super
impressed you I was just resting I was
just like just floor it and I'll just
jump rose what pure trust looks like
that nice Andrew so we're gonna up the
stakes last time here
I know Mario doesn't instantly run
around the sword but this time he's
going to still see how hard that is and
it all ends with a boss sword fight
sword fight
oh man he's later oh oh boy
what what [ __ ]
jeez man Anna's gone to the flood flight
he blocked it [ __ ] looks like you guys
need iron in for the kill try to stop
them like an accident
Oh winner gives you a lot of time I just
stabbed and I stir when they found the
guys to make sure they were dead so
we're going to just do a little bonus to
the fighter test here try to show you
guys what it might look like if we were
playing Castlevania Delord fight cone
goggles bar aqui esta - bien mi amigo
[Music]
completely wrong
oh man all right guys there you go the
real Mario simulator we tried it out
really weird kind of hard but also a lot
of fun difficult yeah I difficult yeah I
made a playlist of actually of my
favorite videos Anna has made